they marched in silence the photos on
their banners spoke loudly enough this
is my father mother and my brother my
brother had cerebral palsy they killed
all three of them in the state of Mexico
my brother couldn't move a finger to
defend himself these are the board facts
in 2019 there were more people murdered
in Mexico than in any other year since
records have been kept behind the
numbers are the intimate horrific
stories like that of a remote community
of dual u.s. Mexican citizens where
women and children were gunned down last
November they were friends and family
and it was you know that there was three
women and six children some of them were
burned and some of them were shot their
relatives marched like this in honor of
a young girl who barefooted led other
children to safety across the hills
President Lopez Obrador chose not to
receive the marchers saying he didn't
want to make his show bad no as here oh
that's the same president who just the
week before used his daily press
conference to announce a raffle for the
presidential plane searching for your
relative isn't a show there's such a
huge desperation when you can't find
your loved ones it's very hard you don't
know what it's like until you live in
the violence in Mexico has been a
constant for more than a decade for the
year into this presidency it's worse
than ever Mr Lopez Obrador main strategy
for solving all of this is a new
militarized security force called the
National Guard but so far it hasn't had
much of an impact and his critics have
asked why isn't he instead improving the
police force that Mexico already has or
the justice system the vast majority of
crimes in the country go unpunished
cabinet ministers would you to meet the
protesters at the end of the March they
have a big task on their hands
and the dead missing and their relatives
are watching John Holman al-jazeera
Mexico City